hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have a doctor Alessandra Sacco
with us she's the associate professor
ageing and regenerative program and
associate dean of curriculum at SBP
Graduate School of biomedical sciences
she's from SBP San Diego California
dr. Socko has won several awards I'm
going to name three of them in 2017 Wow
award for wonderful and original work
annual retreat of SBP faculty in 2014
again war award for wonderful and
original work annual retreat of the SB
MRI faculty 2010 cell paper selected
from the faculty of thousand medicine
2008 net nature self-nature paper
selected from the faculty of thousand
medicine 2005 to 2008 MDA research
development grant in addition she has
published more than 30 peer-reviewed
articles various book chapters and she's
in the editorial board of tons of
journals and she has received several
grants for her work welcome dr. Charcot
I said she was thank you for having me
and for inviting me today
thanks for joining us let's talk about
your background education etc give me a
brief overview sure so I'm I'm from
Italy I was born and raised in Rome
Italy and I studied at a la Sapienza
University in Rome and I completed my
studies there and in in biology in cell
biology and where there I studied the
reactivation of the cell cycle in
differentiated cells so I was working
while I was in Italy mainly in in vitro
of cell culture system and so I was
interested in understanding how they
differentiated
this actually can be regulated and can
be manipulated then after that I decided
to go for a postdoc abroad and because
in Italy there are a lot of
opportunities to grow in science and so
then I decided to come to the United
States and I did my postdoc with Ellen
Blau a stem for university there I've
studied I studied skeletal muscle and
but specifically I started working with
in vivo models and animal models and
that for me was really an awakening
because I got closer to stem-cell
biology really studying the world of
regenerative medicine so how can we
actually repair a tissue and how a
tissue is maintained and so it brought
me to us the question that I'm still
interested in studying today and so
there I work on skeletal muscle
regeneration and specifically developing
strategies to isolate muscle stem cells
and and identifying their potency their
ability to self renew and further I work
on developing a model for muscle disease
which is Duchenne muscular dystrophy
which is progressive regenerate
degenerative disease and so we generated
a neural models that many aspect it's
closer to the disease manifestation in
patients and so it's a useful model for
testing therapeutics I stayed there for
several years for about 80 years so
after my postdoc I became a research
associate and then senior scientist in
Helen blouse lab and then in 2010 I came
to San Diego and I started my own
independent group sanford-burnham Prebys
medical discovery institute which is an
institute in la jolla edges which is a
wonderful area for science because it's
close to major institutions like UCSD
Salk and scripts
and and here I established my own group
where I continued to study skeletal
muscle development and regeneration and
understanding the signals that modulate
stem cell behavior in this tissue and
how can we leverage is this CD signal to
to promote tissue repair and so maintain
a healthy tissue function so in terms of
a little bit more on my myself I'm the
first person in in my family that that
went to university and graduated and so
and I owe these to really the efforts
and sacrifices of my family and I am
very grateful for them for allowing me
to do that so yes good nice nice intro
and tell us about your lab people grad
student poster and all those things
sure so my lab is on average we have
four to five people and and it's a mix
usually it's a 50 50 50 postdocs and
graduate students and then we have
periodically also summer interns so high
school students that come here for the
summer to experience science and the lab
and to see if that's a path that might
be the interested in and so currently we
have one that it's just a stat for this
summer I like to have always a 50/50
between postdocs and students because
I'm also involved in the graduate
program at our Institute so we started
the graduate program at SBP the groud
accredited in 2015 so it's a remedy new
graduate program and i'm involved in the
program being the associate dean of
curriculum so I developed the courses
and the educational activities and I
find that it's it's very rewarding to be
able to mentor trainees at different
stages of their career so postdocs they
already have a more clear vision of
their career so your role in that
context is more like to help them to
achieve their goal and then to move
forward
graduate student the D approach is a
little bit different isn't it to help
them to develop their own vision and
what they want to do and so a lot goes
into having conversation and in trying
to to to gather what actually they would
like to develop and become in terms of
professional career and so I like to
have this variety because you really
like allows me to have like a broader
vision of mentoring younger younger
scientists and I have to say like
mentoring is the most probably the most
rewarding part of of my profession so I
like that very much
now you mentioned about the mentoring
you talked about it and can you please
tell more about your role models and
have you got mentor and how you want to
see it in new era sure different
experiences so when I was in Italy I was
in a very small laboratory and so the
interaction that I would my mentor was a
daily interaction and and so it was a
very close close collaboration with my
mentor when I arrived in the United
States I entered a very big lab at
Stanford University there were over 20
25 people and so it took a little bit of
adjustment so and I'm saying this
because it happens to a lot of people
that are doing this so don't be afraid
it's a normal part of the process and of
the growth and and that helps you
develop more your independence because
then you really find your own identity
in a broader context at that point
you're no mentor every day you're not
that close to your mentor but it allows
you more to actually develop your own
identity I have to say the both of them
have advantages and disadvantages
overall for me experiencing both it was
actually extremely useful for my own for
my own growth in terms of what I do in
in my lab in terms of mentoring I do
have given it it's a small lab and daily
interaction with them but I I do try as
much as possible so my goal is every day
to try to
empower them so not really like stay on
them and really like tell them what to
do
but really it's more about help them
asking the questions and then let give
them space to find the answers and the
approach to find the answers and so
sometimes while at the beginning when
you start your own lab this is difficult
because you need to take a step back
basically you're not gonna be the active
role in every aspect of of the
experiment but that's that's what I find
it's most useful for trainees in terms
of role models well gosh I mean there
are a lot of role models in in my life I
have to say from a personal point of
view the role models for me have been
strong women in my life and so really
like my grandmother and my mother that
they faced a lot of adversities and for
me the value really overall model is the
everyday facing the everyday challenges
is not really like necessarily the big
achievement but really facing with
dignity and strength the everyday
challenges and I find that like an
incredible strength in that in terms of
in terms of scientific role models for
me I am very I have a lot of
appreciation for women who became
faculty decades ago like in the late 70s
and 80s because he was really difficult
at that time for women to enter the
world of academia and and they really
opened open up the the the path for a
lot of us moving forward and so for them
facing this adversity and breaking
basically and to open that path and was
actually for me is extremely educational
for that point of view so yes and like
you talked a lot about your lab and all
like let's just briefly talk about other
than lab like what are their your
hobbies and what else do you do other
than
research all right so I love animals and
so I have cats and I like allowed to
like to spend a lot of time with them
and and so that's one part of my life
but then being in San Diego of course I
love San I love the Sun and I love the
great weather we're very lucky here and
and so I like to be outside in the Sun
for for most of the time I have to say
and then on a more personal note I'm
interested in in psychology so I'm
really interested in we in understanding
psychological behaviors which I think
it's kind of a personal interest for me
but it helps me sometimes because even
in my daily work because one thing that
at the beginning when you are starting
your own lab find difficulties it was
difficult me at the beginning is really
to realize and accept the different
people have different needs and so you
need to approach them differently to
help them to achieve their goal and so
again being interesting in the
psychological aspect of it it it helped
me a lot to be able to to try every day
to do my best to help each person with
their own needs yeah that's interesting
so I haven't heard this answer from
anybody it is important because the grad
student postdocs their needs are
different and individually and now in
the labs like you have people from
different parts of the world so they are
all different they come in there one way
of thinking and all those things so
that's really useful so now going back
to the research like you mentioned about
the stem cells muscles and all those
things so you can give you a small
overview and start your presentation
sure so as I mentioned so we study we
study skeletal muscle and we are
particularly interesting in in stem cell
biology within skeletal muscle and the
interest
for me in skeletal muscle comes from the
fact that it's an essential tissue and
it's affected in a variety of human
diseases so not only this is the
specifically affect muscle but also
diseases that affect other tissues but
they have an indirect effect on muscle
the results of having the reduced muscle
function is actually extremely
validating for a lot of human diseases
and it really like reduced the quality
of life and in some cases it reduces
shorten the lifespan of our patients so
there is an incredible interest in
trying to develop approaches to promote
skeletal muscle repair because that
would have an impact not only in muscle
the generative diseases or in the
context of aging where we know that
skeletal muscle progressively decreased
their function but also in a different
variety of contexts like for example
even in cancer where muscles muscle mass
is progressively reduced for example in
cachexia so try to understand how the
muscle can be repaired and how can we
maintain a healthy function of muscle is
a central question that we have and we
leverage stem cell biology and stem
cells to try to utilize their potency to
achieve this goal so that's the main
aspect the main framework in which we
actually perform our research so would
you like me to start my presentation now
yeah sure alright so let's do this let
me just do this there you go all right
can you see it yep perfect okay so I'm
going to go give a brief overview and
then I'm going to discuss an example of
how we can actually manipulate muscles
themselves and promote skeletal muscle
feel free to interrupt me if there is
any question that you have okay so we
study skeletal muscle and that actually
is an essential tissue
or voluntary movements as we know to
actually be able to walk and also to to
move and also to breathe so it's it's a
fundamental issue that we have for our
life there are over 600 muscle groups in
the human body and skeletal muscle is
also as an incredible ability to adapt
and we can think about for example
athlete athlete there runs marathons
versus athlete that runs 100 meters they
have very different adaptation into how
skeletal muscle perform so as a strong
ability to adapt to its use that we
actually make of it the basic unit of
the skeletal muscle is the Maya fiber
which is a very unique cell because it's
a multinucleated cell is a sensation
that is generated by diffusion of
myogenic progenitors with each other to
form this giant cell that contains all
the structural proteins that are
required for contraction and hence
movement of our of our body
now skeletal muscle as a remarkable
regenerative potential so if we have an
acute injury for example or even if we
have like a strong exercise and we can
have mild damage to the muscle it's able
to repair itself and this is due to the
presence within the tissue of
tissue-specific stem cells that are
called skeletal muscle stem cells as you
can see in the slide on the left this is
the first picture of a muscle stem cells
that was published by Alexander Monro
in 1961 is an electron microscopy
picture you can see these muscle stem
cells that is basically adjacent to the
muscle fibers and underneath the basal
lamina that surrounds each muscle fibers
remarkably already at that time he the
author I puta sized that these cells are
actually be a remnant of embryonic
origin that could be deployed again to
repair the tissue in case of damage and
indeed
now could be true it was a remarkable
like description at the beginning but it
turned out to be true so now that gets
later what we know as you can see on the
right is that muscle stem cells are
present in the tissue and they're
largely in a quiescent state now
quiescence is a state in which cell is
not dividing but is able to respond to
signals and it can be stimulated in
respond to signals and so in response to
stress or in response to injury is able
to activate and undergo proliferation
and through proliferation it can
actually generate much more committed
progenitors that are called myoblast
and and that ultimately they will divide
and it will differentiate and fuse to
repair the damaged myofibers now
throughout this process of course
through the division process muscle stem
cells not only did right biogenic
progenitors but also two more copies of
themselves and this process is called
self renewal and this is a fundamental
process because it ensure that the
number of muscle stem cells in a tissue
is maintained constant and so after an
injury you do not lose muscle stem cells
but they are maintained and they are
ready to be able to respond to the next
round of injury so over the years
specific specific transcription factors
have been identified that mark these
distinct stages so muscle stem cells as
you can see on the graph on the scheme
on the right are marked by the
expression of fact seven-mile a so
committed progenitors are marked by the
expression of my OTE and when they
differentiate and exit the cell cycle
they are marked by the expression of my
or channel and then throughout
differentiation that we start expressing
or the contractile proteins like the
myosins for example that are essential
so in this marker very useful for us to
be able to observe a monitor the
myogenic progression of muscle stem
cells both in a tissue and also
ex-people
if we perform
in culture type of assays now I
mentioned a skeletal muscle as it's very
strong regenerative potential however
this is not always true
there are chronic conditions in which
the ability of the tissue to repair
itself it's compromised and this is and
I'm gonna provide a couple of example
chronic degenerative diseases like for
example muscular dystrophies in which
the constant damage of the tissue leads
over time to the exhaustion of muscle
stem cell function and also in the
context of aging so during aging we do
observe maybe the main the main the most
known manifestation of skeletal muscle
in aging is sarcopenia so it's a
progressive reduction of our muscle mass
however what we know is also that if in
age context we actually have an injury
the ability to repair tissue is actually
much slower and in some cases is
compromised and this is due to
dysfunction in the muscle stem cell
compartment and over the years mostly in
the most recent years there being like
as you can see in this in this slide
several specific processes that have
been identified as as the deregulated in
the context of degenerative diseases in
aging the first one is the loss of
quiescence
and self renewal so upon an injury in
these chronic contacts the cells is
gonna have a defect in self renewing so
in generating more copies of itself and
this progressively is going to lead to a
reduction in a number of stem cells and
so in exhaustion of the muscle stem cell
pool second a speed is increased
myogenic commitment so upon cell
division muscle stem cell in these
contexts can be more biased towards
becoming progenitors are the expenses of
self renewal and again the outcome of
this is going to be a reduced number of
muscle stem cells in a tissue they can
also exhibit an aberrant differentiation
now muscle stem cells are cells that
make muscle their tissue specific
however it has been shown that in for
example in age in context muscle stem
cell can also give rise to two
fibroblasts who adopt a different
phenotype and this is going to be of
course are the expenses of a healthy
repair of the tissue and the fourth one
is cellular senescence cellular
senescence is is a biological condition
in which the cells are no longer
dividing and so they can no longer
respond to stimuli and repair to teach
you properly but they entry in aspect
that has been emerging in the last few
years is that since L in senescence
cells they not only lose their ability
to contribute to the tissue but they
also have a deleterious function in the
tissue because they secrete a variety of
factors that negatively impact the micro
environment so they have a dual negative
effect they are no longer contributing
but they also have a detrimental effect
on the micro environment so these are
four processes that we know that they
are actually contributing to muscle stem
cell dysfunction in chronic degenerative
diseases and aging so what we're
interested in studying in our lab is
what are the signals and what are the
molecular networks they regulate muscle
stem cell behavior and how can we
manipulate these signals to promote
expansion of muscles themselves and then
efficiently efficient repair of the
tissue so what we study here just put a
two main example two main areas that
we're interested in studying in in our
lab the first one is how the muscle stem
cells interact with micro environment so
in the muscle tissue as you can see on
the schematic on on the left
of course the cells are not in a vacuum
there they're actually able to interact
to differ with different cell types
they're very close to the myofibers
which is the mature skeletal muscle
cells but they're also very close to
blood vessels to nerves fiberglass also
a deep aside so fat cells so they are
exposed to a variety of different cell
type
and a variety of signals that are
emanating from these cell types and what
is becoming more and more appreciated in
the recent years is that the signals of
these different cell types are very
important to coordinate temporally
tissue repair so really understanding
how muscle stem cell received this
signal and how it translates this signal
in specific different gene expression is
very important for tissue repair
so one pathway that I'll talk about
today that we're interested in as you
can see in this slide is the jak-stat
signaling pathway now jackster signaling
pathway is very important in mediating
the signals of several secreted
components for example interleukin 6 and
uncle studying m2 side only a couple of
them and upon binding of these factors
with their receptors jak 2 as you can
see here is a kinase phosphorylates tat
3 and entitles in 705 and upon these
phosphorylations that tree can dimerize
and then translocate to the nucleus and
being a transcription factor is going to
regulate transcription of a variety of
genes in in muscle cells and and i'm
gonna talk about a little bit what is
the function of this signaling pathway
muscles themselves and how is important
for cell fate choices in muscles
themselves then a second aspect that i
won't talk about today but is actually
extremely important and is becoming like
a major major question in stem cell
biology is understanding root unity of
the muscle stem cell compartment so in a
population of cells not all cells are
equal they're very different they have
different potencies and they have
different expression of genes and this
can be due to their own autonomous
differences but also it can be due to
the local signals to which they're
exposed to and really studying and
trying to understand the
relevant the composition of this
compartment and how the presence of all
these difference a population is
important for maintaining a healthy
tissue is a question that we are
interested in studying mostly in vivo
with lineage tracing and clonal trace in
in vivo but today our focus on the
signals and specifically just a three
signal pathway that we are studying
we've been studying for the last few
years so what we have shown a few years
ago the paper published in a German is
in 2014 and there was done at the same
time also Mike with Michael Rooney his
group that publish also similar findings
is that upon activation of quiescent
muscles themselves we have activation of
satra signaling and star tree signaling
is very important to promote the
transition of the cells to a committed
stage so to committed progenitors and so
it allows the progression of muscles
themselves through myogenesis so from
the quiescence and activated state to
differentiation and then mature
myofibers these paths will be mostly
studied in culture in in in the past
years but here we were actually studying
in vivo in the context of in vivo animal
models and so what we have shown I'm
just showing a couple of results from
that paper because it was published is
that given that star tree signal is
promoting this commitment of the cells
to the progenitor stage the question was
can we manipulate these signals can we
transiently inhibit start reactivity and
would that result in an expansion of
muscles themselves and then after we
remove the inhibitor now we have a
larger pool of stem cells that can
contribute more efficiently to the
tissue and this turn out to be true so
what we did is that we took a mouse and
we induce an injury and
with in this case with no tech scene but
which is a snake venom toxin that
induced massive significant tissue
damage but there are a variety of
different ways to induce localized
muscle injury and then after this we
injected into the muscle a starter
inhibitor that blocks the activity of
stat3
and then after that basically we monitor
the activity of muscle stem cells and
how the tissue was repairing itself and
as you can see here so when we did this
in young mice at two months of age this
is an astrology is a cross-section of a
muscle so all these round pink circles
are actually muscle fibers you can see
that in muscles injected with the
starter inhibitors the fibers are bigger
and this is due to the fact that I'm not
showing it here that we actually
expanded muscle stem cells that then
contribute more efficiently to tissue
repair and very interesting what we also
observe is that the beneficial effect
was also true when we induce an injury
in an old mouse at 24 months of age
which is an age is an aged mouse we also
observe as you can see on the right a
larger myofibers that you can see that
you can see here when we inject the
starter inhibitors so if we this is just
least one example and so if you
transiently need it a signal that
promote the transition of muscle stem
cell to the progenitor stage you can
basically allow the expansion of the
cells and then these cells are able are
in larger and larger numbers and are
able to repair the tissue more
effectively so this was done in the
context of young in age but we also
tested it in the context of the chronic
degenerative disease which is to share
muscular dystrophy now as I mentioned to
share muscular dystrophy is a chronic
degenerative disease due to mutation the
dystrophin gene and the cause is a
constant damage to the muscle and so
over time the ability of muscle stem
cells to repair the tissue becomes
compromised
now the mouse model that we use here is
the MDX mouse which as as a defect as
register engine as you can see on the
top left this is a Western blot that
shows that in these traffic conditions
we have an elevated phosphorylation of
stat3 so the pathway is constantly and
apparently activated because the muscle
is always damaged and so these results
we have put asides results in basically
a premature commitment of muscle stem
cells so we repeated the same experiment
in that we did for the young and aged
mice in this case we took dystrophic
mouse in this case a more severe models
of dystrophy the mdx MTR we induce the
in we injected the inhibitor in the
muscle for stat3 every week and then
after one month we look at the muscle
stem cells and you can see in the bottom
left that indeed muscle stem cells also
hold satellite cells were more
proliferative in the presence of the
stat3 inhibitors because we are blocking
their commitment and differentiation and
if we look at the muscle fibers you can
see that mice muscles injected with the
starter inhibitors have larger myofibers
and was also measure on the top right as
you can see here so again manipulating
these these pathways weed inhibitors it
allows us to expand the cells and then
promote tissue repair and there are a
lot of inhibitors of the jak-stat
signaling pathway because this pathway
is involved also in several types of
human cancers so there has been a lot of
interest in developing different from
pharmaceutical companies in developing
different inhibitors and so one aspect
that we are developing now is actually
testing these specific inhibitors and
trying to see basically also the
long-term effects of these inhibitors in
tissue in tissue repair but of course I
mean the question after this proof of
concept that actually we can manipulate
a signal that promotes this transition
and as a result improve tissue repair is
what are the downstream effectors of
stuttery signaling in muscle stem cells
so what are the genes that are regulated
transcriptionally by star 3 and what can
we learn about how is actually
promoting this commitment towards
towards myogenic progenitors and so to
do this what we did in the lab is
actually we started by utilizing a
genetic model in which we can delete
that tree specifically muscles
themselves so in this case we utilize as
you can see the scheme on the top impact
7kr
so it's it's basically a model in which
you can delete a tree gene specifically
when you inject mice with tamoxifen and
specifically in muscle stem cells
because they're a combination under the
promoter of Fox 7 which is specific for
muscle stem cells and so we delete the
gene specifically muscles themselves and
then we induce an injury and then we
isolate the cells from the tissue and we
perform RNA sequencing RNA see to see
what are the difference in gene
expression in the presence or absence of
satury and when we did this we can we
have done this both in healthy tissue or
in people where even reading and you see
the heat map there were significant
differences you can see on the left and
on the bottom right you can see that
when we look at control mice and we look
at the difference between regenerating
muscles and healthy muscles you can see
that the pathways the processes they're
mostly affected are proliferating genes
because the cells end up the cell cycle
and start dividing protein synthesis
because the cells start to actually
increase their synthesis the rate of
protein synthesis it also mitochondria
function because during the activation
process the cells undergo metabolic
reprogramming they shift the way they
actually they produce energy and they
increase they mitochondrial respiration
and interestingly if you look at cells
muscle stem cells in which the tree was
ablated you can see that the
mitochondrial function process was no
longer modulated so you can see
proliferation changes and protein
synthesis changes but there were no
longer the metabolic reprogramming has
burning like in healthy issue and so
that led us to try pata sighs the stat3
pathway is actually promoting
mitochondrial function during muscle
stem cell activation to gather a little
bit more evidence about that we actually
isolate the cells and as you can see on
the top we sort the cells and there is
an example of a fax flow cytometry plots
in which we can isolate the cells based
on cell surface markers cd34 and alpha 7
in degree and then we place the cell in
culture and then we measure with the
seahorse as say the the oxygen
consumption radio C re muscles
themselves and you can set you can see
in the bottom of the slide in the muscle
stem cells in which that tree is deleted
we have a reduced mitochondrial
respiration OCR both in basil and the
maximal conditions while actually the
glycolysis measure with the
extracellular acidification rate on the
bottom right was not affected so release
a tree signaling is actually promoting
in muscle stem cells mitochondria
respiration now how does it do that
so what are the genes that are involved
in this process and what is what we are
particularly interested in this is
because it was becoming more and more
evident in recent years they've been
several studies really interested in
understanding how the changes in
metabolism in muscle stem cells but this
is in general rules in stem cell from
other tissues are actually important to
direct cell fate changes and so
regulation of stem cell metabolism
portent to determine what the cells will
become after so we focus on the genes as
you can see here in terms of
understanding the downstream effectors
of satury in genes that change when
during the activation process you can
see see the sixty-three genes that is
actually highlighted here so change the
change during activation in LT tissue
and they are no longer responsive in the
knockout for for step 3 and so we
several of these jeans and one of the
genes that we became interested in was
from three a so found three a is a
ubiquitously expressed cytokine like
protein and it has been shown although
it's not it's not been heavily studied
yet but it's been shown in vitro to
induce mitochondrial respiration in
vascular cells neuronal cells and epatha
sites and so of course I mean there was
an interest that this gene might be
involved in the phenotype that we are
observing in the absence of star tree
signaling so we validated that from 3a
is indeed down regulated in muscle stem
cells without stat3 as you can see in
the bottom right and also when we
isolate muscle stem cells that we use
differentiation into into myotubes so
differentially muscle cells in vitro and
that's a very easy acid that you do
basically with serum starvation so you
reduce the nutrients in the media by
reducing the amount of serum and the
cells spontaneously will differentiate
into mature myotubes as you can see from
3a is actually at the RNA level up
regulated during differentiation and
that is very similar for this to what
happens with that tree that it also
becomes a regulated during
differentiation so they have the same
trend in terms of in terms of RNA levels
during the differentiation process but
of course the next question was well is
this a direct target i mean during RNA
sequence related several genes but is it
directly regulated by stat3 so we by
bioinformatic approaches identified a
pure defined inside of three on the
promoter of an 3a as you can see in the
top left here and so when we took a
myogenic cell line in this case it will
c12 and we actually kept it in growth
conditions and we also stimulated with
il-6 interleukin 6 the stimulate star
tree signaling as you can see here when
we stimulate the cells we start 3 this
is a chromatin immunoprecipitation assay
a chip we can see that actually the step
3 occupy
see on the farm tree a promoter is
increased and that was actually
correlating with an increase in the
h3k27 acetylation mark which is a mark
of active transcription so this
indicated that country a is a direct
transcription of target of stat3 further
- further substantiate this we look at
previously published RNA seek data and
we observe as you can see in the top
right that in correspondence of the
transcription start sites of often 3 a
we have a peak of my OD binding now my
OD is a major transcription factors in
myogenesis that is essential for for the
myogenic transition of muscle stem cells
towards more mature cells and so we
observe this institute 12 in previously
published data and also in ship sig data
of our collaborator Lauren suppori when
he actually convert fibroblasts into
myoblast by overexpression of my OD we
can see again also in this case that my
OD is actually binding in the
correspondence of a start site of found
3 a so this was interesting to us
because we are seeing that that tree is
regulated from 3 a but also my OD which
is an essential an essential
transcription factor for myogenesis the
regulating from 3 a so and this would
actually point who at an network loop in
which both stat3 mio deregulate the
transcription of a gene that might be
involved in metabolic regulation of
muscle stem cells now on the bottom left
you can see that when we isolated muscle
stem cells from mice lucky my OD is the
genetic model lucky my OD the farm 3a
RNA levels are reduced again consistent
with the fact that the gene is regulated
positive regulated by my OD and finally
we actually perform a luciferase assay
is our collaborator reality Ella in
Italy and in which when we have a
construct in which we put the fam tree a
promoter
regulating luciferase and we Co Express
in 293 cells also start 3 and my ot and
you can see that when we actually
overexpressed at 3 mi OD we do have an
increase in the luciferase reporter
activity for fan 3a indicating that
against a free mio d our upstream
regulators of fam 3a gene transcription
so moving forward so this was
interesting to us so we identify the
gene that is actually regulated by
symmetry and by my OD it has been
previously implicated in regulating
mitochondrial function in different cell
types so now the next question was for
us to try to understand what happens
when we manipulate fam 3a so here we
perform an acute loss of function so we
isolate muscle stem cells and we infect
them with the lentivirus
that express an shrna against fan 3a to
block it's to block his expression or an
SH control as you can see in the top
right this is at the RNA level you see
that when you actually inhibit fan 3a
you have a down regulation of my
adrenaline which is a marker of myogenic
differentiation and which is again
consistent with the fact that if you
block from 3 L you block that transition
towards later stages of Maha Genesis and
also we look at the protein level when
we actually knock down from 3a in muscle
stem cells this is in culture as 72
hours in growth condition in the bottom
as in the bottom side of the slide you
can see that when we inhibit from 3a we
do see an expansion of cells that are
expressing PAC 7 this is the dark gray
and the black and so this was suggesting
again consistent with what we observe
with star tree gene deletion so if you
block fan 3a you are actually increasing
the number of cells that are less
committed and blocking a transition
towards more committed stages but this
was done in between acute loss of
function so the next question besides
here is just a validation also that
these results in an inhibition of
expression of my arginine still in vitro
and inhibition of differentiation so the
formation of Multan Clayton
oops expressing myosin heavy chain again
validating that this is a gene that is
required for proper myogenic
differentiation so the next question for
us was to test it in vivo because acute
also function in vitro of course it's
useful but as the limitation of is it
actually happening is the process
happening in vivo so what we did we
generated a knockout mouse model that
the deletion with the deletion of fan 3a
using CRISPR class 9 and then we'll look
at the skeletal muscle
both are fetal stages and postnatally so
here you can see that this is a fetal
stages at the embryonic 15 you can see
that in green there is embryonic myosin
we change the marks mass of fibers and
in red there is laminin you can see that
you have a reduction of the size of the
muscle these are the limbs the lower
limbs of the embryo so you have a
reduction of muscle mass and if you look
at the bottom side of the slides you can
see that this resulted in a reduction on
the number of myogenic positive nuclei
again very similar to what we observed
in vitro so deletion of an 3a is
impairing the ability of masses m cells
to transition to committed progenitors
and then these results in a smaller
muscle mass in the embryo and this was
also true at Berta p0 as you can see
here on the left again a reduction on
the area so the muscle size expressing
embryonic myosin heavy chain and on the
right you can see that this is actually
was correlating with an increase in the
number of packs of a positive muscle
stem cells so we are able if you delete
the gene in also in vivo we are able to
increase the number of muscle stem cells
are the expenses of the differentiation
and so results in a smaller muscle mass
so this is done a fiddle and a needle
stages but now we also look at the mouse
line in the adult and as you can see
here the body weight in the top left is
reduced in this
and these results in the reduction on
the of the muscle mass in several muscle
groups you can see the gastrocnemius and
the quadricep muscles that reduce in
mass interestingly there is a
significant reduction in the heart and
we're exploring that to study the
function of this gene also in the heart
well there was no changes in the other
tissues so really the reduction in
muscle mass was related to the reduction
of the Russian body weight was related
to the reduction in muscle mass so here
so we saw so far what the deletion of
the gene can do to muscle stem cells and
to and to the embryo embryonic
development of the tissue and in the
adult but what is the function how does
this protein work now the protein is
predicted to be secreted and so we
wanted to test that so we took citizen
12 and we over expressed fan 3a tagged
with a mid-cap here and you can see on
the left that the protein is Co
localizing here with the with the ER in
the cell and if we block if we use an
inhibitor of secretion which is Melanson
you can see that the protein accumulates
inside the cells is again in the ER and
indicating that the protein is being
actively secreted by the cells this was
quantified I'm not showing here in terms
of colocalization but further we also
did Western blot and you can see here on
the top right that when we actually
block the secretion with Melanson we
have an accumulation of the flag fan via
a protein in the cell and it's measure
here and finally in the bottom right of
the slides you can see we took the media
and then we did a Western blot in the
media of the transfected cells and we do
see that the fan 3a that we transfected
the protein is present in the media so
all of this evidence together is
actually validating that this protein is
being actively secreted by myogenic
cells but of course being a secreted
factors the resolves the question in the
micro environment that is it only being
secreted by muscle cells or by other
cell types so we really wanted to see
where this signal is coming from in the
muscle
vitamins and so we isolated both in pubs
and in the adult you can see in the in
the left side of these lights we
isolated by flow cytometry muscle stem
cells macrophages martha's mps fibrotic
organic progenitors which is a very
important cell types that can adopt if I
brew genic or in a deep oceanic fate but
it's very important for signaling
muscles themselves and also much
myofibers and you can see if an 3a is
being expressed by all these different
cell types with the majority of it being
expressed by the myofibers and when we
induce an injury in adult tissue you can
see that we can have and then we look at
three and seven days after injury you
can see in the right side of the slides
they we have a transient expression of
this gene in several of these cell types
specifically in fibrin deep oceanic
progenitors and macrophages really
indicating that you both during
development and during regeneration and
the adult regeneration in several
aspirin capitulate the development of
the tissue Iraq reactivated several
signals that are actually present during
development of myogenesis you do see a
transient activation of this protein so
this protein is produced by several of
these specific cell types and so then we
decided to talk about to take advantage
of the function of this protein that is
actually secreted and so we exposed
muscle stem cells either healthy or
lacking stat3 to a recombinant fan 3a
protein so we put the protein in the
media and then we ask can the basically
the exposure of the cells to this
protein rescue the phenotype of the
cells that are lacking stat3
so that was the question to understand
what is the relevance of this gene as a
target of Satria is irrelevant for the
phenotype that we observe and indeed
this is the case because as you can see
in the top right when we expose the
cells to fam 3a you can see in let's
look at the graph that in the starry
knockout cells in the black
they have no trigger conditions they
have a reduction on the percentage of my
training positive cells because the tree
is required for myogenesis but when we
expose these cells of 1 3 a we have a
rescue in the ability of these cells to
express my Janice Meyer journey so in
indicating that this gene is relevant
for the phenotype that we observe with
start 3 knockout cells further this
protein the exposure to the dominant
program was able to rescue the metabolic
phenotype the mitochondrial respiration
because upon exposure on 3a we do see
the muscle stem cells now rescue their
ability to to have proper mitochondrial
function and again the glycolysis was
not affected so is able to rescue the
ability of the cells to commit towards
differentiation and to restore
mitochondrial respiration this is done
in vitro then finally we decided to test
this in vivo and so we took the mouse
model in which with the leads that tree
specifically in muscle stem cells we
induce the gene deletion with tamoxifen
treatment we induce an injury of
skeletal muscle in this case with barium
chloride and then we inject
intramuscularly the fab 3 a recombinant
protein and then we ask as six days
after injury is the muscle regenerating
more effectively and our muscle stem
cells any different in the presence of
this recombinant protein so as you can
see at the center of the slide when we
when we look at the stat 3 knockout
cells these are the black bars in normal
conditions they have an increased number
of parts 7 positive cells because the
cells are accumulating in this
uncommitted state and when we actually
inject fan 3a now we are again
normalizing the numbers of pack 7 cells
in the tissue and if you look at the
bottom part of the slides if we actually
look at my or journey we see the same
thing so the star tree knockout cells
have a defect this is the black bar in
transition into a mile journey in
positive image but if we inject the
recombinant protein now we are rescued
disappear
to actually transition to this stage and
make muscle so altogether what these
would this story that was recently
published a couple of months ago is
actually telling us that upon the
activation of muscle stem cells the star
tree signaling pathway is promoting the
transcription of fan 3a which is a
secreted protein not only by muscle
cells but also from other cells in the
micro environment and this fan 3a is
promoting mitochondrial function and
these promote the commitment of these
cells though were differentiating Pro
training leaders and then making muscle
and of course what we're interested in
now is actually utilizing this as a
potential even more specific target
compared to a tree and trying to see
whether if we can use approaches to
block it and it can be like chemical
compounds or antibodies if we can
actually have in chronic conditions
where actually star tree is chronically
elevated and this protein is is
chronically elevated if we block its
function can we actually now restore and
promote healthy repair of the tissue
this is this conclusion for this part of
the story and so what emerged from this
from this study is the star tree
promotes mitochondrial function in
muscle stem cells is activates the
expression of an 3a and Foundry a
promotes muscle stem cell myogenic
differentiation and if we delete the
gene in vivo is impairing muscle
development and some 3a is a relevant
target of stat 3 because when we
actually expose the cells of fam 3a it
cells that are lock-ins that tree is
able to rescue the phenotype that we
observe so a this is a this story that
tells us that the shed some light on
what is the biological process this tree
is affecting in muscle stem cells which
is mitochondrial function and identified
one gene that is actually relevant for
this specific phenotype we have many
more that we are now testing of course
because the tree activates regulate
several different genes and so
trying to get at the networks that are
actually regulated by this pathway and
what can we learn about these networks
also in chronic conditions so I think I
stopped here I just would like to thank
the people who did the work which is in
my laboratory former members to fan I
dog do and Matthew journey did the stat3
story in the in the genetic deletion in
mice the beat
Salah did the specific studies on fan 3a
and several people in the laboratory
collaborated with these stories our
collaborator Karen suppori and and Greg
duster for the genetic deletion of fan
3a and several others and our funding
sources and just would like to take this
opportunity just to say that we're also
I'm one of the organizer of the
frontiers in Maya Genesis conferences
that will take place in September this
September in 2019 in Costa Rica and we
have an outstanding lineup of speakers
and so I just wanted to put that out
there whoever is interested the the
website link is there and the email is
there and and it's going to be a very
interesting skeletal muscle meeting so
that concludes my presentation and I'm
happy to answer question I'm just going
to go back here and stop the screen
sharing that's a great question so the
receptor is not is not known and we are
looking at that actively right now so we
are utilizing
approaches proteomics approaches to
actually identify cell surface molecules
that are binding to fajn 3a because
really thats a relevant question so not
only the signal but how are the cells
responding and is the receptor modulated
in chronic conditions right now yes we
we are starting to look at that right
now
I agree every time we money we introduce
something in a tissue which is a complex
community of cell types I mean it can be
a protein or it can be even a drug the
effect is not going to be selective on
one cell type effect is going to be on
all the cells that are able to sense the
signal respond to that signal we are
looking now at the vasculature and we
are looking now
also like potential neural cells that
the neuromuscular Junction to see if
there is an effect or if it's a global
basically metabolic signal present in in
in the tissue we have not tested that
yet that's what we wanna that's the next
point yes absolutely anytime again we
are very excited that we are we are
doing it and we hope to have as many
people as possible in terms of the
community that can contribute I'm happy
to talk to you any time about that and
thank you for having me and thank you
for doing this is an incredible resource
so yeah I do yeah thanks